in der trostrunde mache und jeder kann
zeige was im plan
ich verkleide ich bei einer präsenz
tochter andrea glienicker hat mitten in
der stadt bern den sogenannten freien
raum gegründet
für mich ist wichtig für sie ist der ort
wo man hand rogall wende macht so oft
macht will greift und das land weit wie
möglich zu machen und erwachsenen machen
es ist möglich nur so dass mehr ein
umgebung bereitstellen wo motiviere wo
sinnvoll dass stützen des raumes oder
habe gelernt und zwar zu beziehen
wenn so eine stetig braucht ist durchaus
nachmachen ist eigentlich wurscht
umfrage unter aufsicht
aber durch ausprobieren amon teilt vor
den anderen kindern einen vortrag über
ihre nächsten ferien in thailand und es
gibt sind diese mit daher nennt sich
inspirieren
vor dem waschtisch oder was anderes ins
kader machen sind es ist oft so dass
irgendetwas an machen ist und plötzlich
ist es wie ein magnet für ganz viele
dazu und wenn das nachts oder wenn zu
locken
so entstand auch mit foto werden konnte
stoff menschlich deswegen hat er ja
recht wenig hat mir davon profitieren
sie workshops syrien unterschiedlichste
themen die idee vom freiland rom ist
mein kind interesse hände da unterstütze
den fragen gibt der baugebiete musiker
als vater sagte ich denke im fall der
heckel workshop machen
ich finde das ganze ganz cool finden ja
oder nein trifft andere
familien aus dem kloster mit animierten
flug durch andere
[Musik]